[Musique]
pour vous est de venir faire mieux pour
me mêler ajustements à cette chose qui
est celle de diminuer la souffrance des
hommes
pourquoi cette envie diminué française
sommes et peut-être parce que ça me
donnait
un certain rôle une place dans ce monde
qui est un peu qui tout à fait c'est à
dire vous trouvez incohérent oui
désordonnée oui injuste
apparemment oui au juste comme c'est un
clochard qu'on ramène tes clés gelés oui
comme cet avis ya qui est tombée comme
un diagnostic misère physiologique que
oui et comme c'est un ouvrier
que 50 ans qui ont fait qu'à l'heure de
dire oui
alors là est très fier c'est réparé une
injustice réparée atteignit atténuer
pendant le laps de temps qu'il passe
tout au moins c'est de réparer il ya en
france 90 mille infirmières alors qu'il
en faudrait estime-t-on cent cinquante
mille neuf mille d'entre elles sont
employées par l'assistance publique de
paris
à la sortie de l'école leur salaire et
2247 francs après avoir exercé pendant
19 ans elle ne touche que 1856 france
avant de devenir infirmière simone et 8
agents hospitaliers
elle avait 18 ans elle faisait les lits
balayer le sol se travaille dur lui a
appris à connaître la vérité des
hôpitaux on dans les salles de femmes
est la ville angoisse la vieillesse
solitaire et c'est souvent l'image de
leur propre devenir que simone et les
autres infirmières croit déceler sur le
visage des femmes dont elles ont la
garde
bonjour mesdames vous allez bien vous
aider à dormir pas bien pourquoi il y
avait du bruit long j'ai toujours mal à
la tête
oui puis les oreillers vous remuez pour
me désormais plus bas c'est pour ça
est ce que vous croyez simone qu'on peut
mener une existence normale lorsqu'on
vit comme ça comme une infirmière
il faut se débattre il faut la ville
normalement c'est compliqué bien sûr
c'est compliqué disons que j'ai le même
les mêmes points de vue que mon
entourage qui n'est pas du métier non
mais sûr que non et des tas de choses
que je ne vois pas pareil parce que
précisément je suis en contact avec la
souffrance la mort la misère et que moi
quand les gens me disent oui la mort un
bon ben oui moi la mort je regrette mais
c'est quelque chose que tous les jours
c'est tous les jours trois morts par
jour l'hôtel tube oui voilà c'est ça et
pour moi quand j'entends le même il ya
eu tant de morts
et pour moi c'est pas des vains mots ou
surtout des blessés quand vous lisez les
accidents de la route dit il ya eu 30
blessés eh bien je vois déjà le blessé
est un pas la jambe cassée le qui
paralyse et c'est un peu moi c'est pas
des vains mots
alors je vais évidemment peut-être pas
les choses comme quelqu'un qui n'est pas
un métier mais dieu que j'ai peur
une vie normale j'ai combattu
j'ai combattu parce que je pense que
pour être équilibré dans mon travail
pour être bon
sereine enfin pas toujours mais enfin et
puis supporter supporter mon métier il
faut il faut me fallait que j'aie
quelque chose à côté fait que je veux je
vois je sorte que je la défense 5,2
discute que je
je prenne part à la vie chaque matin
c'est la même question
je me demande comment je vais retrouver
ma salle comment les malades ont passé
la nuit et le st celui d'hier
est-ce qu'il est simplement encore et
pour la journée je vais devenir un
personnage comme dans la tragédie
grecque
je vais mettre mon masque il faut que
j'aie un visage lisse serein ne pas
ajouter mon angoisse celle des malades
devenir à la fois la femme qui en impose
et celle qui rassure l'infirmier une
fois vous avez dit je me demande à quoi
se faire de guérir les gens que je vois
dans cette salle de réanimation
c'est une question que l'on se pose
souvent quand on voit les résultats
évidemment la relation je pense que oui
on se pose cette question quand on voit
des êtres trop diminuée après bon les
sauver oui abondé sauver sa cet accord
le grand problème dans ces gens quittent
l'hôpital
tout est à recommencer
oui souvent alors là certains cas alors
là que faire
faire mais ça c'est ça ne concerne pas
que les infirmières le grand problème sa
mère ce qui les problèmes de la société
mow trouve que les hommes devraient
s'organiser nom serait temps
[Musique]